Yeah. Wow. So, I mean, listen,
there are people, uh, you know,
at 10 years on the show,
I was on the show for a long time.
There's people lot longer.
It's people that did the whole 17 years.
People have done well over a hundred,
you know, no one left that show.
You don't leave that show
if you get a spot on it.
Were you with him when,
when it ended?
No. Uh, no. I was with him, um,
about a week and a half
before. Uh, so now, uh,
good friends that were there.
I was in, um, Chicago and uh,
I've woke up and the check my phone
and I got a text from my friend Maynard
Maynard Keenan
from tool and um,
Maynard is a Jujitsu brown belt and
really loves Jujitsu. Any, any, um,
the text me, he said so much for the, uh,
Maynard versus Anthony Bordain
celebrity Jujitsu match
and that's the whole text.
And um,
you know,
just sunk,
sunk a pit in my stomach and I just,
I just picked up my phone and went into
Google and I looked it up and I saw it.
I'm just like,
oh fuck.
I just couldn't believe it.
I couldn't believe it.
Now I just
started crying.
I think. I think I called my wife
had called Maynard or texted him.
I called my wife,
called a few friends,
you know,
just like,
you know, just couldn't believe, you know,
when someone's just not there anymore.
I didn't get to see him a
lot, but I was just, uh,
just appreciate the fuck out
of that dude. You know, like,
I don't want to do anybody's TV show, but
when I got a call from him, I was like,
fuck yeah,
what are we gonna do?
We're gonna shoot pheasants and hunt
and camp and we're going to cook by the
campfire. Fuck, I'm in,
dude. You know, I'm in.
I just really, uh, appreciated
him as a, a genuine,
unique person. Like is
a genuine, rare person.
And uh, you know, that's,
that's what I got out of being,
being able to spend some time with him
and being able to talk to him and pick
his brain. And he did my podcast once
and we always planned on doing it again.
We should,
we never got around to it because
we're both have ridiculous schedules,
but just my,
I would think about things differently
because of him. Like got my,
I would sometimes like hold things to
his standards and e j like legitimately
his appreciation for things,
his enthusiasm for things changed
the way I look at a lot of,
a lot of aspects of food and
culture and, and, and even travel,
you know?
Yeah. I mean, um,
yeah,
I'm sorry ma'am. And I, you know, I, and
I know he thought very highly of you,
and that was, that experience in
Montana was fantastic, man. So fun. Um,
you know,
it's been,
it's been a rough three months and
it's still hard for me to really
contextualize it and put it together. It
feels like, you know, upside down world.
Like there's no, and
he was such a, I mean,
it was a friend and a collaborator,
you know,
but also just such an icon to me,
you know?
Yeah.
And, uh, did, it's almost like, you know,
it's almost like the sun disappears,
you know, or something. It's something
that is so just inherently part of life.
They're in and dependable and you know,
um,
yeah.
So yeah, I mean it's been all right.
It's hard to describe how, how um,
profound that's been.
Um,
okay.
I remember when he got into Jiu Jitsu,
I got site cause I'm like,
we got more to talk about now.
I can actually,
I can actually show him some shit.
And he was always asking about things,
you know, he's really good at things.
Remember when we were in Montana,
we were rolling around on the dirt.
I know shown her stuff, him and Josh,
I was like click when you're in here,
like here's what you can do, you can get
the end. He's like, Oh yeah. He's like,
he was so a wide eyed,
you know,
I think it was before he even got his
blue belt or maybe it was like around blue
belt. So he was super, super jacked
about it and he was doing it every day.
I remember when we were, we were
filming, we were outside of billings.
Is that where we were? Where
were we? Yeah, well we're,
the hunt was on the hunt.
We were in
like a up in central Montana, you know,
so, um, we kind of started in billings,
but we headed up towards central Montana.
He was training so often in,
even on the road that
he traveled to a club,
there was just a Jujitsu club in
Bozeman. Yeah. And he found some guys.
And who's wrong with these guys in
Bozeman? Yeah, yeah, definitely.
Like damn you doing it every day. So that
was a day for a long time on the show.
That was a mandate. We
find the local, you know,
the local clubs and make sure that he
had a place to role texted me from some
European bloc country.
Said he was shitting bone bone chips as a,
he worked out with some old
school Carlson Gracie guys.
They don't believe in rolling light.
It's all top game and smashing you.
And he said, yeah, I'm shitting
bone chips. But I just,
I admired that a guy could be 58 years
old and decide I'm going to learn Jujitsu
and I'm going to be obsessed with it.
And then he became addicted to it, which,
you know, Jujitsu is a very
beneficial thing to be addicted to,
but it is absolutely an addiction.
I've,
I've come back from injuries where I
definitely shouldn't have been yet and
are just wrapped my arm up and just
fucking get in there. People get super,
super addicted to it and he got addicted
to it just like he's been addicted to
many things. He just, he jumped
right into the Jujitsu experience.
Um, well I'm glad he
did. It wasn't me anyway.
It was clearly like really
good for him to us. I mean,
I know very little about your jet,
so I know what I know from Tony,
you know, little slim. Yeah.
He lost all that weight.
All of sudden the out of stocks packs
up smoking. Yeah. You know, those were,
those were big things, man. And uh,
and he looked great and he's, you know,
he got off statens.
It's no longer on any sort of medication.
He lost all that weight, caught all
the carbs out. It was just eating like,
you know, just protein crazy man.
It looks so good. He did look good.
Um, he did look good. Then
I also just, I, you know,
the whole thing was kind of
indicative of the way he was. I mean,
he did things so passionately,
you know,
whether it was travel the
world and soaking up all
these experiences or Jujitsu
or whatever, if he was into something,
if something caught his attention,
he was just so aggressive about knowledge,
learning what he could, pulling everything
out of it that, that he could, you know,
it's crazy to see someone do something
that's that physically demanding. Yeah,
no kidding. 58 with no background
in athletics of the law. Yeah.
Like you could see when he was like,
even when he was doing things,
like when he went to curt,
Osi Anders place and was rolling around
like he doesn't have a background in now,
but he's just pushing himself
to it. Yeah. Yeah. And again,
I think that was true with
everything, you know? I mean, if he,
if it was something that was interesting
to him, he just went, he loved it,
man. It was crazy. And I said, you
know, I remember texting him going like,
how deep you getting into it?
He goes, real fucking deep.
And he goes, but he goes,
he goes, I'm getting tapped
out every day. But he goes,
I'm giving guys half my age
of real struggle. And he
goes, uh, and I'm loving it.
Yeah. And he talked about that a lot. I
mean, I think he talked about like the,
the failure as much as anything else.
I'd love that. Yeah. Going in and,
you know, getting smashed. Yeah. But you
know, again, to his credit, you know,
which show up in these places,
you know, Bozeman, Montana man or,
or Butte,
you know what I mean?
I think he rolled in Butte know a hard
hitting town. Man, listen, I love beauty.
I love you too much respect
to anyone from Butte. But man,
that's a hard hit in town. You know, you
can roll into real cowboys, you know,
and uh, and get the shit kicked out of
him and show up on set all, you know,
sore, bruised and, oh man. Oh yeah.
And then just jump into that. You know,
it's different for a guy who's 58.
I mean you got a guy who does it at 20.
I admire anybody who does Jujitsu cause
it's a real humbling ego dissolving
experience and a lot of ways cause
she's makes you realize like all your
illusions of how well
you can defend yourself.
They go out the window and
some just chokes you easily
and you're like, oh great,
I'm just a bitch. Wanted around running
around this life thinking I'm a man.
But the fact that he did it at 58 just
showed what kind of a unusual duty was.
Yeah. But would you just
talked about there? I mean,
what you're talking about with like the
ego diminishing aspect of it. Again,
I think that that was something that he
took great pleasure in. And I think that,
you know, if you look at the way
he went through the world, um,
one of the things that,
you know,
I appreciated right off the bat and one
of the things that kept me around as
long as I stayed around, you know, um,
cause the fact that it took, you know,
for Tony,
I think that he was constantly
trying to dismantle that persona.
You know, to say like, I'm, I'm
not the focal point of this scene.
The what we're interested in here,
what I'm interested in
talking about is out there.
That's the camera's pointed away from me.
You know,
he was kind of a clearing house for all
that information and he was the root of
the show and it was his journey.
But you know, ultimately, you know,
what was refreshing as he wasn't like
working with some celebrity or hosts that
was completely consumed by their own
ego and their own, you know, brand and,
and how they were presented to the world.
That's so disgusting right now. Yeah.
Tears. But it's, it's everywhere.
It's everywhere. Yeah.
He was very self deprecating and he
had reverence for real artists and real
masters and total reverence.
Yeah. Came across. It came across,
I texted him about some guy,
there was a photo of a restaurant and uh,
I'm sure it's still on my phone.
Some dude who's like a real famous guy
who's like some big time chef character
and I was eating in this restaurant. And
so I'm like, who the fuck is this guy?
I guess it seems like it's a
big deal. And so, uh, I, uh,
I texted him the photo, this cat right
here. Yeah. Do you know that guys?
Was that guy's name? So
I said, who is that guy?
Says Marco Pierre White Made Ramsey
cry like a bitch all the time.
Original rock star, chef genius,
mad man, the original punk.
But that kind of texts, like that's,
that's a Tony Board game text. Um,
that's,
that's what that,
that text shows that reverence
for the master. Oh yeah.
You know, I mean, even the
way he phrases it, you know,
made him cry like a bitch all time.
Original rock star, chef Genius Madman,
you know. And, um, and that's
the way, I mean, what was,
what worked about that is he had a,
like an instant ability to sniff
through the bullshit, you know, so,
you know, there's, listen, there's
all kinds of famous people,
celebrities and you know,
well accomplished people that he met
that he didn't feel that way. You know,
he would cut through that shit instantly,
but if you were on his radar in that way,
you know,
it's like total commitment to
what you do and you were in
or you're out the Anthony
Bordain click. Exactly. Dude.
You want to be in that list
of people is like, yeah,
that's a cool list to be on. Well I just
remember hanging out with them, you know,
like I just,
it was one of those guys,
he was one of the ones that I met
that I was like pretty starstruck.
Like right away I said something
really stupid. Like my wife says,
you're my boyfriend. Cause they've
watched his show all the time.
She would just joke around how you
want your boyfriend on TV? Like,
he's great guys, great,
leave him alone. But, um,
like, uh, when we were in Montana,
that's when I really, well,
I always knew how hard he went,
but when I was blasted out of my mind
and he was like, where's that bottle?
Where's those joints? And I
was like, Jesus, man. Like,
I can't even know I'm hanging
onto the earth here. Well,
I was a late night. Yeah,
it was that one. I mean, I'll listen
to their, like in all fairness,
not every night was
quite like that without,
we had a lot of fun that night for sure.
It was real fun and in
a really interesting,
thoughtful dialogue around the campfire
with super land townie from backwoods
country hunters and anglers and all this,
the other guys that were with us, right,
you,
these guys who,
it was good to get a different perspective
on what going out and getting your
own wild food is like, yeah. You know,
and then having him cook it there and
it was delicious. It was awesome. And,
but also being able to put those ideas
on like a major network and print,
pretty rare.
Man.